so let's talk about it sort of from the
American perspective for a second so you
know it's one thing when we talk about
climate change and we talk about how it
changes resources in the Middle East
because obviously there's a real
scarcity of water whether the climate is
changing or not although it obviously is
but you know you we can use a couple
examples from the United States so first
let's talk about about hurricane sandy
and sort of how did how did climate
change come to play on that then I want
to talk about Florida and Miami
specifically which people are saying may
not even be around in 20 years don't
tell it to rick Scott yeah climate
change is a dirty word
yeah it's remarkable the you know
hurricane sandy is really a great
opportunity to talk about the various
ways that climate change may be
impacting extreme weather events very
damaging extreme weather events so the
one thing we know for certain is that
global sea-level rise caused the storm
surge associated with Sandy at Battery
Park in New York example to be at least
a foot above what it otherwise would
have been a 13 foot storm surge rather
than a 12 foot storm surge and if you do
the calculation just that one extra foot
gives you 25 square miles of additional
coastal flooding and New York along the
Jersey coast they industry groups
totaled up the estimated damage
something like six to seven billion
dollars of additional damage just due to
that one foot yeah wait can you what can
you unpack that a little bit because I
think people maybe don't understand that
that that one foot it doesn't sound like
a lot but actually because water will
just go wherever it's supposed to go it
basically can create mass casts exactly
because you know our coastlines are
generally pretty flat and and so you
know if you add one foot of water to the
ocean surface that allows the water to
extend in potentially many miles just
one foot of water can mean many miles
inland of additional flooding and so
what happened here was
that one extra foot of sea level rise
which we know is due to human-caused
warming of the planet that one extra
foot meant 25 additional square miles of
flooding the flooded area and and
billions of dollars of additional damage
and that's only looking at the one
aspect of Sandy which where there's an
ironclad tie-in to climate change
there's a credible argument that can be
made that the intensity of Sandy was
greater because of the greater warmth of
the ocean and more energy to drive that
storm there's an argument that can be
made that the unusual trajectory that
sandy took and this is where the science
gets really interesting
so most storms curved out to sea but
sandy instead decided to make a beeline
for the Jersey coast in New York City a
very unusual westward track that it took
towards the east coast and that track
was part of a larger scale pattern of
circulation of the atmosphere it had to
do with the unusual jet stream pattern
that prevailed at that time and there's
now quite a bit of work that has
suggested that that particular unusual
jet stream pattern may be favored by the
loss of sea ice in the Arctic and the
loss of sea ice in the Arctic is of
course associated with the warming of
the planet the warming of the Arctic
which is human caused so even there even
in the unusual trajectory that it took
there may be Italian so in and I could
go on and on yeah how do you how do you
guys decide in a case like that where it
sounds like you're speculating somewhat
but you're trying to tie all this
together what would be the piece of
evidence that you could then say okay
well it actually does have to do with
the Arctic ice like what's the actual
thing that makes it all right now we got
that yeah it's a great question that
gets us into a really interesting area
the science in fact there was a report
that came out last week from the
National Academy of Sciences which was
about climate change and extreme weather
events in that that you know how are the
characteristics of extreme weather tied
to climate change and there's an
emerging science to address precise
the sorts of questions that you asked
here and it's sort of like a whodunit
it's sort of like a court case right on
it's sort of like a detective you know
like a murder mystery where you have
some event that happened and you want to
know did climate change you know make
that event substantially more likely
enough more likely that we can basically
say climate change impacted that that
event in some way the magnitude of that
event and what they do what we do
climate scientists is we'll take a
climate model and we can run that
climate model under two different
conditions in the first case under
pre-industrial atmospheric co2
conditions ie an atmosphere that hadn't
yet been impacted by human caused
greenhouse gas increases and you run the
model and you see how often that sort of
event happens in that model then you run
the model again with elevated levels of
co2 in the atmosphere corresponding to
the carbon that we've put into the
atmosphere and you can see how much of a
difference that made in terms of the
frequency and the magnitude of that kind
of event and the scientific community is
is really making a lot of progress in
bringing those sorts of tools to
addressing questions like you know the
California drought what was the role of
climate change in the California drought
in the heavy flooding events in Texas mm
hm
last year in an event like hurricane
sandy so we are now able to to start to
provide some meaningful answers to those
questions all right so with all that in
mind let's talk about Florida for a
second because as you said they have a
Republican Governor Rick Scott he's not
big on anything that you have laid out
here for the past half-hour a lot of
people are saying that Miami I've been
to Miami many times I like Miami great
Beach that Miami literally could be
underwater in 20 years
is that true you
and it's ironic right because if anybody
is on the front lines of climate change
right now it's it's Florida the southern
Florida Miami Miami Beach in its I have
family who spend half the year down in
Boca Raton in the same area and I can
tell you that there's this event it's a
seasonal event you get these very high
tides called king tides and they've
always been it's a natural you know
phenomenon but what happens now is when
those king tides arrive the streets of
Miami get flooded that didn't used to
happen mm-hmm
and each time it arrives now the
flooding increases in extent where you
know Fort Lauderdale is now getting
flooded or inland parts of Fort
Lauderdale and that's the way that we're
going to see the impacts of climate
change
it isn't just going to be some slow
inundate creeping sort of inundation of
the oceans what it means is that the
extreme events are going to become more
extreme and a flooding event that we
might have been able to deal with that
the sea walls that they've built might
have been able to to keep out will no
longer be adequate and we will get
recurrent flooding eventually the
flooding becomes so recurrent that
there's nothing you can do but retreat
right Leslie retreat yeah I mean that's
an incredibly depressing thought so in
the case of Miami you know they've got
some of these sea walls and you know we
know that New Orleans had the levees and
the levees failed and we can talk about
that a little bit too but if you look at
this from the idea of twenty years from
now that's what that's the number I keep
hearing that it could be something like
20 years that's a very short amount of
time all things considered
so is there literally anything with all
the info that you have is there anything
that can be done for Miami at this point
yeah I mean we typically we talk about
two things when we talk about dealing
with climate change you talk about
mitigation which is to say let's prevent
as much additional climate change as we
can we're already committed to a certain
amount of warming of the planet from the
carbon we've already burned it's already
in the atmosphere and the earth is still
catching up to the increases in sea
- from a decade ago there's a certain
amount of committed further warming a
certain amount of committed additional
sea level rise we think that at least at
this point we could adapt to the changes
that are already locked in that are
already baked in what we can't adapt to
is if we continue with business as usual
burning of fossil fuels for several more
decades we're gonna be beyond the danger
zone we're gonna be at a point where we
can no longer meaningfully adapt to many
of the changes whether it's building sea
wells and levees - to protect our coasts
or literally slowly migrating inland
with our major cities that can be done
over a time scale of hundreds of years
right if when you ask you know what if
you try to relocate New York City or a
Miami Beach you know let alone any of
the other major coastal cities in the
world in ten years twenty years that may
be beyond our ability beyond our
capacity so to a large extent it's about
slowing the warming as much as we can
and preventing as much additional
climate change as we can
in the hope that we are still within our
adaptive capacity the changes that are
locked in we can probably deal with it's
going to require a lot of investment a
new infrastructure it's gonna be you
know a lot a much larger effort than the
Apollo project right and and this is
sort of where politics is always behind
certainly behind the science but even
behind the people because I think if if
the real populous heard the types of
things in a more mainstream way that
you're saying they would say yeah we
need to deal with this now but of course
you have a governor who's always worried
about re-election so doesn't want to put
money into a long-term project cuz he's
gonna be long gone by the time that
happens but do you think we're getting
to the point where humans will not be
able to live in a place that's below sea
level so New Orleans for example which
is as you know of course below sea level
so the sea is here
New Orleans is here we create these
levies to artificially allow ourselves
to live in these places are we just
getting to a point where that just
simply won't be passed
yes and you were talking about you know
the politicians who continue to deny
that anything's happening and it always
reminds me of the famous Upton Sinclair
quote it's hard to get a man to
understand something when his salary
depends on not understanding it yeah
well that's politics or no odd right
there right so in and so some of that is
willful ignorance especially given just
how decisive the scientific evidence now
is the person on the street now gets it
the latest Gallup polling shows I think
it's something like 70% of the
population that now recognizes that
climate is changing and that there's a
human role in that and you know we've
had 30 percent that doesn't well you
know you always have a 25 to 30 percent
fringe and almost any issue that you
Paul's it's right for 70 cent that's
pretty good 70 percent that's remarkable
70 percent of the public even despite
the ongoing disinformation campaign
funded by fossil fuel interests and the
Koch brothers which has really been
aimed at hampering the efforts of the
scientific community to inform the
public basically our efforts have faced
this stiff headwind of industry-funded
misinformation and disinformation but
despite that because people are seeing
it with their own two eyes people are
seeing the impacts of climate change
directly in their own lives and it makes
it very hard to deny something's
happening when people see it themselves
so I think we are at that point you know
with Katrina and New Orleans it's a
great example of a worst-case scenario
the largest impacts of climate change
are going to be on the most vulnerable
okay and there are various reasons for
that there are a lot of very large
populations and low-lying coastal
regions of the world like Bangladesh
food products production the the the
ironic twist here is that we could
potentially see slight increases in
agricultural productivity here in parts
of the US because of warmer winters and
longer growing seasons but in the
tropics where they're already struggling
you know where you have developing
nations that are struggling to meet
their food needs there is likely to be a
very sharp decrease in agricultural
productivity from even a little bit of
warming so there's this you know there
are issues of justice and inequality
that come into it but you know you take
New Orleans that was a very vulnerable
population it was vulnerable because as
you say it's a city that's already under
sea level yeah and that means that it
was highly vulnerable to a combination
of factors which we know are leading to
greater flooding sea level rise plus
more intense hurricanes and there is
evidence that climate change is also
increasing the intensity of the
strongest storms whether or not we're
seeing more tropical cyclones or fewer
that's almost irrelevant there is a
debate about that the the impacts
overwhelmingly come from the biggest
storms like Katrina like Sandy and here
you had a very vulnerable situation a
city that's below sea level and a
population that was you know a fairly
poor population a large population of
poverty you know of impoverished people
who didn't have the resources didn't
have the resources to contend with a
catastrophic event of that sort yeah
well if one good thing came out of
Katrina my dog I adopted her she was a
rescue after the hurricane you know they
sent the dogs all her place she actually
gave birth in in New Orleans in a box
during the hurricane and her puppies
were saved and and I got her a couple
months after that but it's a little bit
yeah it's it's she's great she lived in
New York she's lived in LA now she's had
quite a life
is a little list of man versus God kind
of stuff because I think there's a
certain amount of people that even if
they buy into everything that you've
said here they're argue they would say
we'll just build bigger levees right
build higher walls build higher levees
and let's let's see what happens but
that's just not a solution yeah you know
it's if we were to keep warming below
about two degrees Celsius or
we there already and with another decade
or two in business as usual burning of
fossil fuels will cross that threshold
of two degrees Celsius it's three and a
half degrees Fahrenheit warming of the
planet relative to pre-industrial time
that's the level of warming that most
scientists who study the impacts of
climate change will tell you where we
really start to get into that danger
zone where the changes become so large
that they exceed our adaptive capacity
we do have some adaptive capacity for
changes that occur slowly that we can
you know build infrastructure to deal
with we can adapt to those changes but
when those changes come rapidly then
very quickly they exceed our ability
there's no sea wall that we can build to
prevent the flooding of the city there
is no change in the cultivars we grow
that can adapt to the worsening drought
conditions there and one could go on the
events become so extreme and so damaging
because of the aggravating effects of
climate change that there's simply no
way to adapt the presidential science
advisor John Holdren I think
characterized it in a very thoughtful
way he said you know how we deal with
climate change is going to be a
combination of three different
approaches mitigation lowering our
carbon emissions adaptation dealing with
the changes that are happening through
infrastructure etc or suffering and and
and arguably our role is to minimize
that last category yeah all right well
I'm glad you went there with this
because we've been sort of focusing on
the American perspective here but
there's obviously a huge global issue
here so you know I live in Los Angeles
and you know we we're very green here so
you know I can't get plastic bags at
Trader Joe's I have to pay if I get a
paper bag even you know you're supposed
to bring your own bags so we do these
little things and you know I sort of
think they're they're nice to do but in
the grand scheme of things I don't know
that we're really doing anything but I
think being aware of it in and of itself
is good
but then when we think about the wider
world and there's countries like India
and China that are going through their
industrial revolutions now so all the
stuff that we used to put out all the
carbon emissions and all that stuff that
we used to put out in the 20s and 30s
and 40s in massive amounts they're doing
now and I know that the leaders of the
countries they meet in the UN talks
about this stuff and there's sort of a
disconnect because it's like we already
got the advantages that that burning all
that bad allows and it almost feels
you know like who are we to tell them
what to do so a lot of this has to do
with governments now trying to battle
back and forth with what they can do
right yeah absolutely and that's why
these negotiations are so are so tough
right because we can point to the
developing nations and say right now you
guys are the major source of any growth
in carbon emissions and they can look at
us and say exactly what you said hey you
guys got your turn you had two centuries
of free access to this dirty you know
source of energy that allowed you to
grow your economies why shouldn't we
have our turn and and it's a compelling
argument if we don't do everything if
the industrial world doesn't do
everything that it can that doesn't do
it you know that the industrial world
doesn't do its share in in combating
this problem and that's where the
negotiations become so tough you know
the developing world will say well you
also need to make reparations no you
already did some damage to the climate
we've suffered as a result of it you
should give us some money basically
right and that money will help us in our
transition away from fossil fuels
towards green energy towards renewable
energy and so those negotiations quickly
become very contentious they're easily
politicized and you know you know what's
already a very partisan political
atmosphere you can imagine how
challenging it has been for the the
Obama administration to you know to
participate fully in
the latest summit the Paris climate
summit yeah knowing that they're going
to be they're gonna see efforts by the
Republican Congress to undo everything
that they're trying to do it makes it
very tough in the end I would say that
you know we have seen some real progress
China and the US did come to a bilateral
agreement last year to lower their
carbon emissions the two largest
emitters on the planet us because of our
historical emissions China especially
because of their dramatically growing
emissions they've now exceeded us in
terms of total carbon emissions we
exceed more on a we we exceed them on a
per capita basis mm-hm there was this
agreement between both China and the
u.s. to lower carbon emissions the US
will bring its emissions down over the
next decade to two decades China will
peak their emissions since they're not
as far along the curve just getting them
to bring it to a peak is a real
accomplishment and that's where you see
a little bit of a disparity a little bit
of a concession to the developing nation
versus the industrial nation and those
are the sorts of difficult you know
negotiations that we're going to need
and which are now happening through this
process through you know Paris the Paris
summit where we did see major
international progress in combating this
problem who actually police's this stuff
I mean does the UN really have a group
of people that go from country to
country and test all this and report
back and and are there punishments I
mean when you know a lot of times we see
it with the UN on security things
especially I mean think about what's
going on in Syria there's a lot of
documents signed and condemnation of
this and that doesn't really mean
anything in real terms who's actually
doing the policing here yeah that's a
great question and and and no these are
international agreements don't have the
force of law and the IPCC is now sort of
recognized that embraced that so rather
than talking about you know policing and
and and you know and penalizing
countries that don't
meet their obligations there instead
using you know what you could call a
name and shame approach yeah which is
those countries that aren't meeting
their obligations you know the UN will
make it no you know which countries are
and which aren't and to me it's sort of
like you know being the guy you know
being the family whose lawn is never
maintained very well and you've got all
your neighbors and they have beautiful
lawns there's some pressure on you to
step up your game right and I think the
same principle holds here as most of the
world commits to substantial reductions
and in Paris we got an agreement that
basically will take our emissions down
about 50% not enough to keep us below
that dangerous 2 degrees Celsius 3 and a
half Fahrenheit warming but it will get
us halfway there and get us on a pathway
where we can see down the road the
possibility of truly getting to where we
need to go yeah and the way they did
that was really through peer pressure
you know once one set of countries makes
some commitments others are looking over
their shoulder they don't want to be the
ones who are you know are are pilloried
so basically shame is our biggest weapon
in the tool in the fight against climate
change you know different from life
right from the way you know we don't the
the main policing of our actions is by
is through sort of you know an
understanding of what sort of behavior
is and is not acceptable right and I
guess what's a better option I mean
we're gonna bomb these people into you
know submitting to the regulations we
want you know you brought up lawns as an
example and as I said I'm in Los Angeles
I I've only lived here for three years
and in the time that I've lived here I
can honestly say I've seen 50% if not
more of the lawns in the area that I
live in they've all gone drought
resistant so it's a lot of succulents a
lot of rock gardens a lot of there's
like a new rubber sort of thing that
looks sort of like dirt because we are
in a mass
massive droughts here so I guess two
things one how much can we attribute the
drought to manmade climate change and
two are we gonna be able to get out of
this because you know even when I drive
up north I've driven to you know UC
Davis and all along the road for hours
not only are there no crops but there
are signs the farmers saying look what
Sacramento you know our state capitol
has done they're not giving us the water
they're giving it to you city guys
except we're the ones growing the food
take a look it looks like interstellar
around here yeah that's right and and
some of the water is going to natural
gas companies which has been you know
contentious issue as well I personally
know the Governor Jerry Brown talked
with them on a number of occasions he
really gets this problem and and and I
think he sees it actually as part of his
legacy he wants to make sure that
California does what it can to act on
this problem to set an example for the
rest of the world and sorry I
kudos to Jerry Brown he's doing a lot to
help us make progress on this issue but
he is dealing with this and maybe that's
part of it he is seeing firsthand as the
governor of California the direct
impacts of climate change in is to the
first part of your question yes there is
a connection there is some debate within
the scientific literature about whether
the very low rainfall and snowfall
amounts over the past several years
whether we can truly attribute that to
climate change because that relates to
the pattern of the jet stream and that's
one of the more subtle questions in fact
we talked about that earlier how the jet
stream is impacted by the warming of the
planet that's still sort of at the
cutting edge of the science and saying
exactly what impact that will have so in
my view the very low amounts of
precipitation are actually tied to
climate change I think there are
scientists who've made a compelling case
that even that piece is tied to climate
change but even if it weren't water soil
moisture drought is a product of two
things it's how much water you getting
either through rainfall or through the
melt of snowpack in the Sierra that runs
off in spring
how much you're getting and how much
you're losing to evaporation from the
ground from the soils and one of the
simplest relationships in all of
atmospheric science is that as you warm
the surface you will get more
evaporation and so even if climate
change hasn't impacted the amount that's
coming down it's increased the amount
that we're losing and making a drought
worse because of it and even this El
Nino a lot of folks we're looking to
this latest major El Nino event you look
back at the 1997-98 El Nino and that was
a very wet year over a large part of
California so there was this hope that
this latest El Nino event would be a
Soaker like so if it basically just
didn't happen right we're supposed to be
in it right now is that right yeah it
did not the El Nino definitely happened
what didn't materialize was the impact
that El Nino is supposed to have on
rainfall in the western US and it's got
some scientists scratching our heads
wondering for example if El Nino may no
longer be operating the same way it used
to be right that it used to so to those
who thought well at least we can rely on
intermittent El Nino events to give us
to make up for that water deficit even
that's unclear and so California still
finds itself a large powder part of
California I think most of California
even after some some reasonable amounts
of rain and snow in the northern half of
the state even even after that
California is still in major drought
over most of its area so related to the
California one of the things I hear
people say a lot is that we should
invest in desalinization plants which
basically is taking seawater and getting
the salt out of it it's a little more
complex than that but that's the general
idea and then you can drink that and
this is done all over the world one of
the things you hear against that is that
it takes a tremendous amount of energy
to do that so where do you fall on that
do you think it's it would be a good use
of resources to help us with our water
situation or are we then using too much
energy which is going to cause all sorts
of other problems to make it worthwhile
great question it has no simple answer
you know in the end it comes down to can
we afford to lose California you know I
think a sacrifice or not we can write we
know that it's literally too big to fail
yeah um you know we can't lose
California as a you know because of its
contributions to our agriculture but
also because then just the natural
wonders that you know it's just it's a
unique you know state with you know that
that when we think about ourselves as a
country we take pride in the in the
Golden State and I went to school at UC
Berkeley and I'm tied to the state of
California and so I don't think we're
gonna decide that we can just give up on
California that means that we will have
to find a way to meet the water resource
needs that you know the state of
California has despite the worsening of
drought and that may indeed point
towards you know building major
desalinization plants California is
lucky in that regard it you know it's on
the Pacific Ocean right other inland
states in the West that are suffering
similar droughts won't have that
available to them so at least with you
know in the case of California there's
this huge amount of water right at your
back door
the only problem is it's salty but the
physics of that is pretty simple you
know we we know how to get rid of salt
we know that when you evaporate salt
water the moisture that evaporates is
you know loses its salt it's fresh and
then you condense it and water beads
beads of water condensation and that's
gonna be pure water right so that
process though as you allude to is
expensive it's expensive from an energy
standpoint so there's sort of this
quandary right too much energy and the
burning of fossil fuels got us into this
problem in the first place and problems
like this are gonna cause us to need to
use even more energy that sounds like a
vicious cycle that sounds like
hockey-stick kind of
right well the way out of that vicious
cycle is if that energy isn't coming
from the burning of fossil fuels then we
can do it and so once again it speaks to
the need to incentivize clean energy and
and here you've got to hand it once
again to Jerry Brown he recognizes that
it would be inconsistent for him to talk
about building desalinization plants and
not talking about finding ways to get
energy without burning fossil fuels for
this reason and that's what he's trying
to do he's trying to get us you know off
fossil fuels and you know implement the
sorts of you know strategies that
California's going to need to implement
to meet its you know water resource
needs in a world where you know
California is even drier than it used to
be yeah alright so we've talked a lot of
science here now I want to wrap this up
with a little science slash science
fiction because I'm a big science
fiction guy and I mentioned interstellar
before I even liked Waterworld I like a
lot of these dystopian future kind of
movies and in every science fiction TV
show now you know it's that a met you
know I was gonna say Americans but
humans have destroyed planet Earth and
we have to go to other worlds now we
know we're trying to do stuff on Mars
and if you watch the Martian you know a
lot of that was based in actual science
which was nice to science the hell out
of this exactly exactly
so for the science fiction element of
this I mean as you said before you know
there it was here before humans it's
gonna be here after us I mean do at some
point do you really do you that you
think we can fix some of this and hope
that we can fix some of this but are we
gonna have to leave I mean is that the
point of humanity at some level is we're
gonna have to just jump planets because
we're gonna we're gonna suck the
resources out of this one like a
cockroach and then just move on to the
next one well you know it's funny
because there there is this contingent
that firmly believes that that the
solution to this problem is colonizing
another planet and it's a sort of techno
optimism an unbridled techno optimism
that I think I like that phrase
yeah it's sort of on its face it's sort
of absurd right because what you're
saying is we don't have what it takes to
figure out how to implement existing
technology would you know we could meet
a hundred percent of our projected
energy needs from renewables only and
there's a scientist one of the leading
scientists studying this stuff Marc
Jacobson at Stanford has written a
report a peer-reviewed article about
this the climate solutions project he's
part of that along with folks like Mark
Ruffalo trying to get that message out
so we we don't even have to invent the
new technology we simply have to scale
up and incentivize existing technology
to solve this problem and so to me there
there's this remarkable did sort of
discordance beat you know in a certain
group of people who think that we we
don't have the smarts to solve this
problem the easy way but we can you know
colonize other planets somehow able to
do that even though we don't know of any
planet within light-years that could
possibly be a home to us or other living
things given any existing technology
that we have you know that's funny I
never thought of it so specifically but
is there a real split in the science
community you know people like you that
are saying let's let's fix it let's do
the best we can here versus you know I
guess the people that are trying to get
to Mars in a way they have a vested
interest not that they want this but
there's some interest in ship getting
worse here because then you know more
resources will go to them I hate to be
that cynical but you know it's my house
my work yeah I think the most
enlightened folks in that group people
like Elon Musk actually get it right
because he's all about renewable energy
he's all about acting on climate change
I think he's called it the biggest
threat that we face but he's also of
them all about space SpaceX getting the
other planets exploration and a good
friend of mine used to be a neighbor of
yours he's now in New York I think he
spent some time out in LA Bill Nye the
Science Guy I'm working on get a mother
Joe he'd be wonderful and and he's
become a very important sort of advocate
for you know climate for a sane
discussion about climate change again
somebody who is all about exploration
he's the president of the Planetary
Society that was founded by Carl Sagan
but he also is a major proponent of
acting to avert a climate catastrophe so
there doesn't need to be you know those
people who get it understand that you
can be in support of both of these
things yeah we have to explore because
that's you know we've always explored
that's it's a part of our being and we
have this need to do it but we have to
get our own house in order we can't
assume that we'll find some other planet
that we can live on and and where you
start to find that sort of discordance
is in a certain group of physicists and
I love physicists I studied physics at
UC Berkeley I went to graduate school in
physics so I'm all about physics but I
have to say that some of my physics
colleagues is a certain subgroup of the
physics community that really is sort of
not just techno optimists but I'll call
them techno pollyannas okay because they
just have this irrational faith and it
really is faith right we're talking
about science right that technology can
solve any problem
among them is a world-famous theoretical
physicist Freeman Dyson mm-hmm and he is
a bit of a climate change contrarian
he's often quoted
sort of disputing aspects of the science
of climate change and he's all about you
know these sort of there's even
something called the Dyson Sphere which
is this about civilizations that will
build huge
spherical structures surrounding their
Sun to absorb all of the radiation
radiative energy of their star and use
that to drive their so he is all about
you know how sci-fi sort of merges
futurism to envision you know ways that
we could again sort of innovate our way
out of various predicaments but a lot of
that stuff literally is the stuff of
sci-fi so while he's opposed to doing
the basic things that we could do right
now to help solve this problem he's all
about pursuing extravagant and fanciful
almost sci-fi high-tech solutions to a
problem where there's a much simpler
solution right well we have it yeah I
think that's a perfect way to wrap this
up because it's science it's science
fiction it's it's faith it's it's
everything wrapped up and that's why
this is so complex so I think we should
do this again we'll do it one year from
today we'll send you down to Miami to
your family we'll see if you're under
water and I'll do it from probably the
desert of Los Angeles although hopefully
not and we'll see what happens how does
that sound sounds like a date all right
well I want to thank dr. Michael Eman
for joining me today and you can check
out his book the hockey stick and the
climate Wars and tweet dr. Mann all your
climate denial theories it's Michael
Eman with two N's and thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week